[Music]
all right
so we all know that Florida there's some
crazy and bent what are you insane
Florida I didn't say anything crazy
stuff happens in Florida yeah it's like
I don't know like you think of certain
things uh there's also another place
China you say China and certain things
come to mind and for some crazy-ass [ __ ]
in China I think of this you could say
that joke no I was thinking about like
pigeons and stuff they like bridges you
know I want to eat a pigeon you see the
video of that lady catching those
pigeons and then they finally she was
taking them to the restaurant know she
owned a restaurant in China no I think
was in New York Florida oh I know that
only China Florida Florida China pigeon
was raised on Doritos is I would never
eat a pigeon a pigeon is like they say
they're like flying rats but what
there's a term so when they serve pigeon
right it's they don't call it pigeons as
it is it pheasant
yeah there's another term in a
restaurant so they don't but a Cornish
hen it's like one of those names so if
they change your name so you're like oh
it's delicious it's like how mahi-mahi
was originally called dolphin fish and
then people like I don't eat at all fit
yeah or like Chilean sea bass yeah what
was that called something else and they
just changed the name and people started
buying it yeah branding really makes a
difference
true anyways in China something
miraculously happened yet so sinister
happened at the same time and that
question I which what to make it felt
like everything in China it does so a
mom gave birth to twins
right okay that's the cool part that's
the miracle part yeah yeah twins the
strangest part though is when they gave
the DNA test of the babies they found
out that the babies have two different
fathers so being twins they are actually
not
twins she got come down twice but two
different guys the same day so
scientifically they're saying she must
be some sex with the father that with
the husband and then within 24 hours she
had say someone else or what was just
double penetration we keep it simple
threesome yeah I could have been a
Chinese origin oh they do do those out
there I heard so there was how did two
eggs that came out there's two eggs and
apparently two sperms too but then they
find a lot more in two sperms maybe
there could have been four dicks
quadruple penetration and then only two
of them been jogging so there are more
healthy ones yeah what if she was a part
of a gangbang cream pie yeah but only
two made it so they've got those two
deserve a gold medal I think yeah yeah
the rest went on the face and the boobs
yeah they just decide to test twins to
see how they had different dads I asked
the same questions too and I looked it
up and in and in China if you have more
than one child like you're starting with
your second child you have to get a DNA
test for it to be a registered baby
because like in China they have the
whole like first child thing yeah but
then ever since they got rid of the
whole for the one-child policy or
whatever now any second third fourth
fifth child on so onward you have to get
it registered in the [ __ ] baby
database in China why but not the first
child the first child doesn't have to be
registered no not the first one the fact
that she had twins she had to choose one
to register yeah well with any gift of
both right up right there and pin in
there Asian you still have that like
first child is like the best one yeah
mellowness that makes me think that
since only the second and onward have to
get registered that at one point if they
decide we're overpopulated they just
looked up all the second write them out
yeah I do wonder now because of the
one-child policy
what happens when people get twins what
the [ __ ] is this
which one you wanna grab first yeah the
second one that comes out you're like
okay this one can go away follow the
girl that one's definitely out
yeah you give me the gender first you
keep the boys and then send the baby the
girls that American to be a doctor by
some way fam you know that is a issue
right now there's too many guys there's
girls yeah
statistically there is a like a like a
whole like correlation with crime and
gender equality yeah if there's more
guys and they're not getting laid
usually more crime where there's less
sex and more hunger that's when there's
the most violence so I'm wondering why
China don't have more crime I do the
joint order exactly that's true you know
they like to lie about numbers of here
they do yeah they're a big liar of
numbers yeah or they don't even call it
crime yeah they just don't see it as
right that's just normal as Chinese but
yeah so question if you were the husband
right and you find out this this
bombshell information of having twins
and one of them not being your actual
son do you raise them both what do you
do see as cute as Isaac though let's
give it let's give it the benefit of
that all right I'll tell you this so you
have a asian baby and the other ones a
Hispanic baby no I mean like coming from
a not a fat father right like I'm not a
father but I'll give you a head come no
I'll give you advice coming from a human
being with feelings maybe yeah yeah no I
might I might even break that because I
was already thinking like let's say I
have my blood right [ __ ] this was
cool mmm-hmm and then this other one
he's giving me problems and [ __ ] [ __ ]
what if the other one was super cool
okay that one
[Laughter]
we have to wait years to find out
they're cool or not whoa cuz in the
beginning there you know yeah right now
you're as a dad you know right
immediately if the core what kind of you
knew Tiger was gonna be cool so moment
you had the nerd baby that you kind of
see you kind of see where their
personality all like a lot of it it's
just in a very primitive phase so like
in the beginning Tiger used to laugh at
everything already so you kind of know
he's kind of like this happy like he
loves humor he's like a funny guy and
it's just as he gets older he has more
and more things that make him laugh and
he also does funny things yeah so you're
just like oh like I've been seeing him
laugh but then I've also seen like some
kids just from the get-go they're kind
of just like more bratty a little bit
and I'm later on they turn into like a
[ __ ] like I get brother with the
opposite so I was like a perfect baby
like zero through five was like the
chillest [ __ ] baby I yeah laugh at
everything like hardly ever cried like
just the chillest [ __ ] baby and then
my brother would throw tantrums
everywhere I like just everywhere out in
public everywhere and then as we grew
older like I was the more emotional one
and he was like the more chill one and I
don't know I don't think anyone expected
that plot twist in my family
yeah like plot twist I'm crazy that's
when maybe actually nurture overpowered
the nature yeah maybe yeah the tiger
wasn't a shy baby nice never been shy
like I know babies that like you give
them a gift it's not with the mom or dad
though you give them to someone else
they could tell and they just start
crying until they go back you'll go with
anybody yeah it's kind of bad yeah you
got candy yeah I think he just visited
grandma and then so grandma and Jill's
brother lives together
and then so I think Jill is gonna help
grandma like put up like wallpaper or
something in the house and who's gonna
watch tyka and then though what if we
just have him play with this cousins so
the uncle came and she was I don't know
he'd be cool cuz he hasn't really seen
him in a long time and he comes we go
come here tiger go he just jumps on they
just leave
I love the video where he's telling you
to have more girlfriends come over we
did this like 20 quit my ass tiger 20
questions and then one of the questions
I was like hey tiger should I have more
girls come over here yes but he said
like he screamed it yeah yeah yeah
babies always do flip though yeah he's
gonna be sad at everything yeah he's
like not that I think sad but like I
think to be like like like being at home
before like when he was like five or six
like he couldn't wait to come to the JK
office you couldn't wait to go to IHOP
you couldn't wait to like you know do
whatever then yeah we used to go out and
do stuff all the time and he'd be
excited to go out and in fact he want to
go out more than more than me and TIFF
wanted to go out nowadays it's like it's
it's like a whole negotiation process to
even convince them like hey maybe we
should just go for a walk outside
well you're not cool anymore I know that
Bart watch out for that the feelings
that come with the when your child goes
you're not your lane I don't want to go
with you anymore I'm still trying to get
over that you know I know it's a process
of life but I think Steve and I are
gonna be the parents that overcomes they
were like we're cool let's [ __ ] what are
you talking about we show up another
friends down the leg we're just here to
hang we start dressing like them cool
like we're wearing glasses picture to a
sunglasses you got my image I'm so so
small smoke some weed would you would
you smoke some pies no I don't like
smoking weed Oh true maybe I could show
them how much it sucks by smoking you
scared of everything you know what it is
you guys are too thirsty I'd be so if
you deprive them of your love they
always want you
so just ignore him do what my dad day
great parenting
yeah well you see you want your dad's
for the rest of your life oh no I don't
actually it doesn't work that way you're
right I take that back man it doesn't
work that way okay overcome busy you
can't like you could be thirsty it'd be
all the way thirsty relaying it to
things oh I'm so [ __ ] cool you need a
recognizes I think I'm already thirsty
because I think that the phase that
Isaac's in right now Tycho's also in
sick of people though he's playing what
stuff and I'm trying to join him like no
and then what's funny it's a guy daddy's
gonna leave you wanna play with that so
I go somewhere else right so you I think
he just wants me next to him yeah but I
can't be playing with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
such an introvert [ __ ] Power Move man
he knows he's got you he's like oh I'm
gonna tell you go away no you come back
you're bad the day he was in his he has
his little Jeep right shut us to Igor
and then he has this little Jeep that he
drives her on our neighborhood and it's
I'm on my bike and I'm just biking
around and the whole time wants to chase
you on his Jeep yeah I think that it's
his OCD Ness where I like you need to
come here and stand right here and just
stand right here while I do my [ __ ] so
the minute I'm like like riding my bike
no no come back
he's pretty controlling I think so I
think he has OCD Wow I will see you too
so or maybe he just like sometimes I
just want to do my own [ __ ] but then I
want you to see what I did
[Music]
[Music]